we have this story from timcast.com
DeSantis campaign uses AI generated deep
fake images of trump embracing fauci
into it yes yes
hugging and kissing and I also want to
point out look at Trump's see his hand
right here look at Trump's seven foot
long arm
he's embracing fauci and his arm goes
all the way around Factory like just
think about how long his left arm is and
how he's holding fouchy and then how his
other arm wraps all the way around yeah
it's clearly a deep fake and so this is
this is the DeSantis war room they ran
an ad says Donald Trump became a
household name by firing countless
people on television but when it came to
fauci in the video they run this image
it says real life Trump and the top left
the bottom Mill and bottom right are AI
generated images of trump hugging and
kissing Dr fauci wow now look
people like this this people thought
this was real this this video I believe
it's actually from it's from uh
or is it from June 5th I think the
original post is actually a few a few
days before but let's just say June 5th
because that's the date listed on
Twitter
nobody knows anything until today I saw
people posting saying hey wait a minute
The Descendants campaign generated fake
images to smear Donald Trump as favoring
Dr fauci you don't need the smear Trump
he wouldn't fire the guy he says he
couldn't schedule F that I understand
but he very much let Dr fauci do his
thing during covid the fact that they
went this far they opened the gates
yo this is look we're talking about
indictments we're talking about the doj
welcome to Modern politics they're going
to start generating fake AI images of
you doing something to smear you and
this is a serious ad meant to make
people believe Donald Trump actually was
good friends with fauci oh my gosh this
should have a disclaimer that that's
fake because a cartoon you would know
they're defending it they're doubling
down all the decision supporters are
doubling down hardcore saying we are
allowed to do this because Donald Trump
once posted a picture of Rhonda said is
writing a rhinoceros which everyone
thought was real of course at the time
and you know people didn't want oh my
gosh because of the animal cruelty
here's a picture of Ron Anna rhinoceros
and and the response I got was hey Tim
what diss because I said the the
intentional Act of making a fake image
putting it in a collage to trick people
into thinking that Trump was was liked
Dr fauci
is one million times different from
Trump insulting Ron DeSantis also yeah
no in in there's context to those
photographs too which you mentioned it's
in a collage of other photographs but
they're talking about Trump being too
soft on fauci and it's a real life Trump
on it it will and Trump was not making
any specific Claim about firstly it's
poorly photoshopped it's obviously a
joke but secondly Trump was not making
like a claim about DeSantis riding
rhinos
so so opinion everybody responded to me
saying why aren't you disavowing Donald
Trump for his use of deep fakes and I
said what what use and they post that
and I'm like that's a Photoshop of Ron
on a rhinoceros are you joking and you
know it's fake he has a suit on well
right
my favorite Putin riding a bear and they
said they said Donald Trump made a fake
posted a fake AI Twitter space and I
said you mean with the devil and Hitler
so here's what I tweeted I said you know
what they're all mad I say I hereby
disavow Trump for posting a video of the
devil and Hitler in a chat room making
fun of DeSantis Manny DeSantis
supporters thought it was real and it
was wrong for Trump to post it then when
this guy tweets at me what about this
picture and it's Trump writing or it's
Rhonda said is writing a rhinoceros I
said I once again I hereby once again
disavowed Donald J Trump he posted a
picture of Rhonda said as writing a
rhinoceros and many of the Santa
supporters thought it was real it was
wrong of trump to mislead these people
in this way and Trump must apologize for
confusing de Santa supporters with this
image and the dude deleted it
the the the argument that you can make
fake news fake images to trick people is
in no way the same as Trump being a dick
and then people are like how come what
about Alex bruceowitz he posts memes yes
there there was an image of George shows
in the background somewhere and then he
posted something this was another thing
they're criticizing him for where he
said apparently this wasn't George Soros
but I have to wonder and it's like okay
and then other people random people
online who are not Donald Trump and
associated with his campaign posted
photoshopped images of like Christina
Pasha and other people in the DeSantis
Camp there is a big difference between
Ron desantis's official campaign his
staff producing fake images to trick
people into thinking Trump did a thing
he did not do and Trump posting a
picture of Rana rhinoceros but I'm sorry
I guess if they really believe that
happened they were like Well Ron never
wrote a rhinoceros Trump's lying but
here's the thing I'm a highly trained
skeptic so when I saw that picture of
Ron and a rhinoceros I didn't think it
was real but I thought man this deep
fake technology is getting convincing
that's right this is clearly Ron
DeSantis on a rhino I'm sorry like dude
you can by all means criticize any Trump
supporter for posting fake information
100 but the idea that because some
people associated with Trump posted
questionable things they found on the
internet justifies the intentional Act
of posting deep fakes to lie about
Donald Trump this is It's laughably
absurd sorry have a nice day I I was
saying before that I was like you know I
really like to see at this he does great
in Florida he's given us everything he's
wanted his Charisma is not there I'm
leaning towards Trump simply because
Trump's likely to fire all these people
now there is absolutely no way I will
support Rhonda Santos unless he comes
out explicitly disavowing the use of
deep fakes to manipulate people
I think that probably these strategists
he has all this money sense of how do we
go let's keep on this fouchy Crusade
that he was so close to vouch you
wouldn't fire him and maybe the pictures
didn't have that hug so let's just shove
in the hug right let's just add these
two extra pictures it will really push
the envelope and show how close they
were and people won't pick up on it
that's fake but you know not just a hug
a kiss like you know they could have
just settled for a hug they got one
where he's smooching them right on the
noses
they wrote real life Trump they show a
bunch of real clips of trump saying why
he wouldn't fire fauci legitimate
criticism and then it says real life
Trump and it shows him hugging his
saying look at this to the left the
White House the the room doesn't even
make sense but the White House emblem it
says
because AI can't make language they
could have at least photoshopped so what
was their argument that real life was
only written on the pictures that were
actually literally real so they weren't
trying to they were no no no that's what
they're saying the one that no there's
nothing this was on it I don't believe
it yes it is oh those were in the ad yes
I'll play the ad for you I'll pull it up
these are in the ad like
let's play the yes there you go you're
fired you're all fired all four are
fired you're fired you're fired today I
walk in I hear I'm gonna fire him I'm
not firing you I think he's a wonderful
guy should you have fired fouchy so a
lot of people ask me that question and I
did it right because if you do fire him
you're gonna have a Firestone on the
left again why why did you feel unable
to fire
personally you're not allowed to every
time he goes on television there's
always a bomb but there's a bigger bomb
if you firearm frankly
you can't win that one if I would have
done it I would have taken heat all
right I'm gonna say when it said real
life Trump on a picture of him hugging
fauci that isn't real Trump has grounds
to sue yes yeah well absolutely look at
this it's in the video and there's a uh
we've got bird watcher whatever it's
called Community notes at at 25 seconds
in this video a collage of photos of
President Trump hugging Anthony fauci
appear these pictures are not real there
and AI generated images and it says real
life Trump I think that while quoting
Trump fake fake fake to Santa's campaign
should get ahead of this and be like
these were deep fakes before they get
sued into Oblivion oh no dude there's no
debate anymore you're right you're right
there's no debate any any now debate
Ronda Sanders tries to have with Trump
trump wins instantly he's gonna set Ron
is going to be alive Donald Trump
wouldn't fire Dr fauci and Trump's gonna
be like fake news he made fake photos
and ran those I can here it is and said
they were
and I've been very clear about where I
stand on Trump versus DeSantis but I
will say that undermines one of the good
points that Santa's actually does have
about Trump that that undermines one of
the good arguments against Trump even
though I support him to say yeah he
didn't fire fauci that was a serious
flaw he should have is something that is
credible and it's powerful and to
completely undermine that by having a
hand generated picture of him kissing
fouchy on the nose while he hugs him and
writing yeah hey wife what would your
crisis response team be to something
like this double down or what to the
Santos how does your response be
probably should disavow or if he fired
somebody that created this then it would
he's got to find the top blame somebody
else
supporting it say this was their idea I
didn't put up in fake photos in an ad
it's not just putting up a meme on
Twitter it's different right you had to
go through a whole process let's make
the ad let's make it scoop what do you
put here put the photo and somebody said
let's put two fake
three
and DeSantis has to know about it they
had to bring him the ad at the end yeah
what I noticed didn't happen it's
possible that Santas didn't go I'm
Rhonda santis and I approve this message
they used to have to do that or would do
that in commercials it's possible even
if rack no this is warm it was it was
according to multiple reports Christina
Pasha who employed directly by DeSantis
run made this account I don't know who
made the video but it's possible to
Santa saw the video and it's a 40 second
video and he looks at he's like it's
great run it not realizing they put deep
fakes in it yeah but I think if they try
and pull a we didn't know and so we're
gonna hire John herbowitz he was the one
who did it I will not be satisfied I
don't know who that is you can't come to
me and say underling is at fault nah
sorry look man we knew this was coming
we've warned about it it's one thing and
it's bad enough that they cut Trump out
of context and lie about him it is also
bad enough that there are people who
support Trump that make fake things and
then they get shared by people in the
trump in the Trump camp like in in like
the Trump's Circle and things like that
but to intentionally run an ad with fake
images to smear your political opponent
is crossing the line directly and it
opens the door to a very dark future
that's why it's like hey we knew someone
was going to do it Rhonda Santa said he
was going to lead out but man it says re
that this is real it says Trump with a
picture of him that is not real life
Trump so good God what did you guys do
this really opens up the floodgates for
RFK to do it to ads against Biden right
I just we were talking about this before
the show and I was just saying I can't
imagine Trump's going to run ads Trump
is going to make an ad and it's going to
be it's going to be like some woman it's
gonna packs are going to do this so if
you're gonna hear a woman go Ron
desantis's campaign is making fake
images of trump to smear him don't trust
dishonest Ron they're going to be
running that like crazy it'll be like an
image of a serpent with Ron's head on it
and stuff like that all these wild deep
things and it's gonna say real life Ron
I'm a Fisher
but but anything now that Rhonda Santa
says Trump can easily be like are you
gonna believe him the guy who makes fake
images to win arguments I like I don't
want to insult Ron but I get the vibe
that like he's just a guy that was in
the right place at the right time that
he's not really special he's not really
super smart he doesn't have the best
people around him and now they want him
in the public because they don't like
Donald Trump so anyone will do this
guy's establishment let's just get him
up there he'll be fine I disagree I
think that's a little harsh so I um
again I I prefer Trump as of now but
also
um DeSantis is somebody who did stand up
to the covid regime and the lockdown
regime and he pushed back against it and
he did stand up to the meeting I do
think he's very intelligent I wouldn't
go as far as to say he's just like a
mediocre politician like the rest of
them I think he's a step above
I will vote that what covet was was
groundbreaking yeah almost You could
argue that it saved the Republic in a
way or was a it was an it was an
indication of how to save a republican I
I will not I won't I won't support
specifically is a genius move it is such
a potent attack especially because there
are so many Trump supporters who do have
so many questions about operation warp
speed and fauci but they just overplayed
their their hand for no good reason this
was like a very stupid misplay you
didn't have to do it Trump was already
praising operation warp speed still he
didn't fire fauci for whatever reason
and that's a whole different
conversation and they could have kept
hitting him on this but such an unforced
error is so stupid thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time